joining us now here from NBC sports
Boston is our friend Tom Karen how are
you Tom
tremendous rich how you doing buddy we
had to give you a call we had a phone
you up because we have been talking
about that quarterback room in New
England since the day Brady left and you
kept telling us at Stidham it's gonna be
Stidham and now Andy Dalton is a free
agent and I'm wondering if the
cash-strapped Patriots would figure out
a way to bring Andy Dalton to New
England I really don't know if they are
anxious to do so I mean I was told early
on in the process that and when Brady
was still a patriot that the Patriots
were not going to be going that holdover
veteran type route mid tier guy so
that's what I've stuck with I haven't
been disabused to that so I think we saw
last week with what they did in the
draft that they feel okay about Stidham
to me Andy Dalton is just a souped up
Brian Hoyer it's the same kind of guy
and what are you gonna get see that's
the thing rich is trying to figure out
what the Patriots are you know Mike
Florio tried to say okay who are the 10
teams that Sean Payton was talking about
as in terms of our consequential in the
NFL because there's Ted every year and
Mike immediately included the Patriots
and I wonder if that's even true I
wonder if the Patriots are consequential
team in 2020 because when you look at
the status of their roster I don't think
they are they don't have the cap room to
bring on Andy Dalton a and B whether you
bring on Andy Dalton or not I don't know
this is gonna be a team that goes better
than 10 and 6 or 11 and 5 and goes very
deep so find out what you got instead
yeah I guess that's the idea is find out
what you have it's did him but Dalton
you know I know you souped up Brian
Hoyer by the way that's I disagree with
that
I mean that that that is some because I
mean he does have some good numbers in
in in Cincinnati Tom he just he just did
not he did not perform well under the
lights that's the that's the one thing
you could say about Dalton
and in New England they're gonna be
playing a lot of games under lights you
know because they're the New England
Patriots they're Belichick it's post
Brady but you know again it really is is
what is the evaluation to Stidham that's
really what it is right maybe I have a
higher regard for a lawyer than most
people do and again he's got a four pick
playoff game where he submarined his
team before it was out of the first
quarter once so that's what people are
stuck with - I don't think who is that
bad I don't think certainly don't think
that Andy Dalton is an offensive option
I don't I so I don't want to make it
sound that way but what are you as the
New England Patriots what are you trying
to achieve this year because
championship driven is nice and
everything but I don't think that they
can seriously look in the mirror and say
that we're championship driven this year
they have to build in a lot of different
spots so I just think it's prolonging
the inevitable if you bring in Andy
Dalton to take over that spot because
he's still gonna sit there and watch
Jarrett's do them all year he's coming
in to start so what what what is what
what will New England's philosophy for
2020 be Tom what's their prognosis
what's their philosophy you know cuz
you're he has to be to to tear the
band-aid off financially they're taking
the bite with the thirteen million
dollars for Brady another four million
dollars kicking around from Antonio
Brown there's about twenty million
dollars in dead cap money maybe more
that's hitting their cap so tear the
band-aid off there in the graph
you know they moved back but what they
got was a second round pick who's
probably a year away at a position
that's older but good so Kyle Duggar
comes in and he learns how to place
young in McCourty so he's not even a guy
who's gonna walk in and contribute the
Patriots are sending every signal they
can that they're rebuilding and they
acknowledge that they did in the second
round with you know two tight ends who
are complementary but you know project
guys they've sent it in free agency they
didn't go out spending you know I just
think that you know that is their
philosophy this year we're going to be
smarter we're going to be tougher
Riaan still a culture we're going to be
a post Brady team that figures out who
it is and what it wants to be but I just
think it's it's fascinating to watch and
that's why we keep talking about it but
it's it's not what people think it's not
going to be a continuation of what we
just saw for the last decade nor for the
last two decades is this and heaven
forbid for me even suppose it but I
would suppose it if it was another team
I would absolutely suppose it if it was
another team but not one that obviously
Bill Belichick would be in charge of
coaching but you have to ask the
question is this a tank for Trevor
situation that we're watching in
progress tom car no they're not taking
for Trevor kiss you're never going to be
bad enough to get into the top ten I
mean it worse they're going to be 6 and
10 just because they're too well coached
I really don't think that they're
tanking I think they're trying to figure
out who they are this reminds me
completely of the 2000 season when
Belichick came in and the team was in
financial disarray and you had to
fumigate and clean out a lot of the
roster now they don't have to reboot the
culture and they don't have to cut as
many guys but there are they are in the
worst financial straits they've been in
in two decades there's and that's the
interesting thing look how much better
life with a bit of France where it's
just tank instead of a guy with a bad
hips if you don't know how good he's
gonna be you'd have Joe burrow but
culturally that was too far a bridge too
far for them to cross and I think that
that would be with the Patriots would
steal as well we're not gonna we're not
going to do that I'm not gonna do that
to Patrick Chung and Devin McCourty
ADATA Hightower and tell them you know
what we're gonna suck this here so go
out and put yourself at risk every
Sunday
it's just you you know it too and you're
just asking it but no I do know it too
and I but that's I had to I had to ask
the question because if it was Miami if
it was you know the Jets and even a team
that's near and dear to my heart
you know Nate named another team I would
have I would have essentially asked that
question because how in the world are
you going to follow up one of the most
successful tenures any team is
had in any sport how are you going to
follow that up when you know one of the
main the half of the main characters of
that dynasty has left and is set up to
win a Super Bowl and is set up to
succeed and took one of your main pieces
in Gronk mm-hmm but how are you gonna go
into that season and say you know what
if we go six and ten we're gonna look
for the long haul understand obviously
Belichick is playing a long game here
because he has no intention of retiring
to that great kitchen setup that he has
so that's the reason why I asked the
question yeah it's it's fair but again
when we look at quarterbacks in general
what the Patriots have done at the
position over the years and still one
has been remarkable a sixth round pick a
seventh round pick at Matt Cassel it
didn't play in college still got him 11
wins Brian Hoyer
has been kicking around the NFL for 11
years now he was undrafted Jimmy
Garoppolo from division 2 they were able
to craft him into a guy who's got a
hundred million dollar contract Cobra
set became a starter in in Indianapolis
they're gonna have great confidence they
can develop a guy without having to tank
for the player that people say is going
to be so great who then in five years is
going to pose incredible financial
issues if the team does succeed I just
think that I don't know this for a fact
but when you look at what they did with
Brady and their confidence that they
could do very look if Andy Dalton was
their quarterback since 2010 I swear to
you and Brady wasn't here and Andy
Dalton was their quarterback from 2010
to 2020 if you hit Belichick with the
truth sir serum and said would you want
to sue well I bet he'd say yeah yeah we
won a Super Bowl Tommy that's how often
right Tom Caron of NBC Sports Boston
here on the Rich Eisen show and your
latest column at NBC sports.com if it's
up to fans Bill Parcells is never
getting into Patriots Hall of Fame we
were kind of discussing it here in the
New York New Jersey guy next to my New
England guys like of course he's getting
in the Hall
Fame in the New England guys go Oh hold
on a minute you know so I give you the
floor on what this is all about what's
being played out right now in Patriots
land yeah it's fascinating Patriots
started a Hall of Fame in 2007 they said
one guy in at a time well they didn't
know what was going to happen for the
next 13 years was going to create such a
line at the front door they also made it
fan vote we as a selection committee put
up three candidates and every year we
put up the three candidates and on the
fans vote on them and every time
Parcells have been one of the three
candidates up for a vote he finishes a
distant third so you get a 79 year old
who helped rebuild this franchise and
legitimize it and took it to a Super
Bowl and made it so much more compelling
that it was who unless he is somehow
assured into the Hall through the
backdoor is probably not going to get in
before he passes away that's the truth
it's Welker it's Mankins it's variable
with Seymour's Wilfork it's Gronkowski
it's Brady's Belichick it's you cannot
put ourselves on with any of those
people and expect him to get it so to me
I think they have to backdoor the
situation because it's Patriots fans
don't forget what happened in 96 and
they don't forget that from 97 or 2000
he actively you know tried to undercut
the Patriots at every turn well walk
walk through what what he did in 96 for
people who don't know or remember oh
sure in 96 Terry Glenn was on the draft
board the Patriots wanted to follow the
draft board Bobby Greer and Robert Kraft
and Parcells did not want Terry Glenn so
he was overruled they took Glen and that
field parcels and crafts relationship in
that time table and as a result at the
end of that season when the Patriots
made it to the Super Bowl because the
Jacksonville Jaguars knocked off at
Denver Broncos and the Patriots didn't
have to play the Broncos Patriots end up
in the Super Bowl when Parcells was
already signed sealed delivered to Newt
to the Jets and he spent the portion of
the week on the phone trying to figure
out a way to get himself to New York
well he didn't fly home with the
Patriots after they lost that Super Bowl
and soon
thereafter he got himself to the Jets
and after he got the Jets
he signed Curtis Martin to a poison pill
contract the next year and he did
everything he could to wrangle and
rankle the Patriots for the next three
years and then when don't balichek was
set to quit and come to doing one
ourselves tried to block them so
Patriots fans remember well all that
stuff and that's why when you put it in
their hands they go no he was a traitor
well yeah
so I guess but by that respect I don't
know do the Jets fans have a vote on
whether Belichick gets into the Jets
Hall of Fame you know cuz I mean look i
mean when you when you're when you're
gonna put it all into it
I mean Belichick would let's put it this
way would Belichick be the current coach
of the Patriots if Parcells never walked
through the door great question I don't
know would they have crossed paths
someplace else with my papers I don't
you know what I mean like seriously
again Belichick went to England if I
said walk through the door that's it
they could be in Hartford Connecticut I
remember that I remember that when I was
on my oh yeah they were talking about it
seriously Tom right and that was even
after they were successful that's when
Pete Carroll was here they they were
just talking about it he sat down and
signed the contract to go to Hartford
crafted with the with the governor John
Roland I'll send you the picture no it's
like he's gonna be sick to his stomach
amen
I was on SportsCenter at the time and we
were all sitting there saying are we
gonna have an NFL team in our backyard
are we literally gonna be able to sit
here in Bristol I'm serious
we're gonna be sitting here on
SportsCenter in Bristol Connecticut and
take a ten less than 10 minute drive
depending on traffic and be in an NFL
facility are we really gonna do that and
that's and I was walking around and that
was just a few weeks after I was so
stunned that in NF and NHL team played
in the mall in Hartford you know I went
to see yoga and an lamu by the way I
think both about a hat trick one night
against the poor Hartford wail you know
in the mall and I remember sitting there
thinking are we really gonna get the
Patriots here in Hartford and obviously
that didn't happen but you know Kraft is
who he is and where he is in the pan
Dioner the NFL for you know in his own
right but it did start with Kraft
turning to bill right and changing
everything around and Parcells is the
one who brought Belichick to New England
and then he brought Bella check with him
to the Jets and then when the Jets and
Parcells you know fell apart with Leon
hats the owner of the Jets I mean let's
go let's do the whole lineage here Leon
has the owner of the Jets sold the team
of Woody Johnson and and I guess
Belichick read the writing on the wall
and he's like I'm I'm going to New
England and he he resigned on a cocktail
napkin and that was the end of that
would any of that happen if Parcells had
never walked through the door in New
England any of it yeah
I mean one detail on that too was
Parcells was actually hired by James
Bush our North line Kraft bought the
team after Parcells was named head coach
so it wasn't craft pick so that was kind
of a Leon Hess Woody Johnson situation
or Parcells right a little bit dead he
didn't escape from so but his thing
Parcells being who he is and craft being
who he is right the men be in 79 years
old they should have a day here and they
should find a way to get it done because
they're close to the end in the
beginning quite suddenly as we all are I
guess that's the ultimate question and
then and then we could you know spend a
couple minutes on one other subject but
it does imagine it just I guess it all
comes down to what what rkk thinks of
all this what is Robert Kraft think I
think he likes the opportunity to show
that hatchets are buried and we'll see
if he comes up with a way to do it Stacy
who you know Stacey games has a lot of
effort and sweat into that Hall of Fame
and crafting it in a certain way and
every year he busts his ass to make sure
that we do a good job to put it together
yep
so it kind of would suck if we figure
out a different way to get a guy into
the club it is outside the realm sure I
think Stacey would say what are we doing
we can't do this but we'll see what
happens Tom Curren of NBC Sports Boston
here
Rich Eisen show what's the grant fallout
any nothing specific I think that people
here in New England as they often do
once he ended up in Tampa were quick to
say you know what screw him anyway
because he really did laaser an exit
that was Belichick Ian in some ways
belcheck Ian because you know he he
timed it up so that they were right up
against cap and said hey I'm coming back
you're getting the treatment of this one
team or I'll come back to your team you
know so it was he really backed them
into a corner unruhe tiring so no team
was going to trade for him knowing that
he wouldn't report to them
the Patriots couldn't cut him hmm
because then he would have gotten what
he wanted they would have got no
compensation and they couldn't call this
blessing and you know had him rostered
because then they would have been over
the cap so it was a fairly shrewd move
we'll see honestly how Belichick used
that in the future what what will his
relationship be like was Gronkowski
because of all the guys who didn't have
a say in where they landed for able
Seymour Mankins on and on and on Malloy
Gronkowski ends up being the guy who
orchestrates a departure on his terms
and gets what he wants
it's kind of funny so how much rich
Gronk and how much is it is agent saying
let me handle this is Gronk really
playing three-dimensional chess somebody
might have tapped him on the shoulder is
good hey if you do this it'll work you
surprised if it wasn't he's a rosenhouse
guy still right Krunk yeah yeah sure
yeah maybe
Drew's got such a good relationship with
Belichick and would never want to damage
that I think that well I mean he would
have to call bill up and and smooth that
over because I mean if this is you know
the way that you
you've put it out there it sure seems
like um or you could sit here and say
that Bella check kind of made the first
move to try and send him to Detroit to
Patricia right 100% 100% but you could
also say King wasn't meat was Gordy
Kowski the guy's got five kids who
played in the NFL right
he knows the landscape he figured it out
on his own what am I supposed to do hey
he's only doing it look this is a
business man but it all comes down to it
you know it you know it I know it's all
about a business and we'd love talking
about loyalty for a reason we love
talking about loyalty because we're so
loyal to our teams in our cities and
what the team is and that's the Jerry
Seinfeld phrase it we don't root for the
players we root for the laundry you know
we root for for the uniform but
obviously we root for players certainly
when we fall in love with them people
like Gronk are so lovable but when it
comes down to it you just mentioned all
the history of some of these great
people who you say will get the red
jacket to get in the Patriots Hall of
Fame before Parcells and for good reason
who they are what they've done to the
team many of them wound up somewhere
else and a couple years before their end
of their so-called usefulness and it's
you know that's just the nature of the
business its nature the Beast
we've seen it right now in green right a
little bit you know in a way right a
hundred percent and they're all they're
all self-employed contractors they're
all their own little industries really
not only that but they're fighting for a
finite piece of pie in a salary cap so
they're actually pitted against each
other yet they're still able to live
within that green house or you know
protected element where they're all with
each other and pulling in the same
direction it's it's fascinating because
they are they're fighting over the same
money and who's gonna get more of it so
professional sports in a salary cap era
is really it shouldn't work but it does
last one for you Tom again I know I keep
knocking on this door and you're saying
that it's still the answer is it's Jared
Stidham cam if cam saw we saw what what
Jameis Winston who I have at the top of
my third hour today signed for and in
newing Inn in New Orleans can't there's
no there's no shot
I mean why wouldn't New England want to
take a chance on somebody that does have
six seven eight years of usefulness that
does sell jerseys that do does put
Fanny's in the seats and I know that's
not Bella checks ultimate concern but
does have an immense amount ability a
chip on his shoulder he's just thirty
there's no shot of this guy winding up
in New England I just don't think he
takes care of the football well enough
if you look at his his interception
ratio if you look at his arm strength if
he honestly look at his accuracy only
had one year in which it was over sixty
I think it was at 67% in that one year
and that was two years ago but it just
isn't really the quarterback that the
Patriots have usually embraced now maybe
they changed the way they do things but
you know I was told pretty I said look
am i safe continuing to say that there's
no shot was shared with Cam Newton
coming in and I was told I was safe with
that Tom appreciate the time NBC sports
balls territory now all we'll be
checking in with you periodically man I
really appreciate the time no trouble
have a great week right back at you
that's Tom Curren get down calling him
from New England
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here